vinieron de Ecuador México Colombia
Honduras 500 mujeres indígenas de todo
el continente se reunieron en Guatemala
para enfrentar juntas las políticas de
exclusión que sufren desde hace 230 años
y la celebración por la llegada de
Cristobal Colón a américa no entró en la
agenda de la Cumbre parte de esa
política
institucionalizada de del racismo que
existe país es querernos decir de que el
12 de octubre es el día que nos
descubrieron que a partir del 12 de
octubre empezó la civilización en
nuestros estados para nosotros el 12 de
octubre ha sido uno de los días más más
crueles más oscuros de nuestra historia
el país anfitrión cuenta con un 50% de
mallas garifunas y afrodescendientes y
dentro de esos pueblos la pobreza es
300% más fuerte que en el resto de
Guatemala pero la mayor exclusión la
vive en las mujeres por vestir la ropa
que las identifican como indígenas las
que hemos venido luchando somos las
mujeres porque somos las víctimas de
estas discriminación por lo que
encontraron en el uso de sus trajes una
manera de resistir está todo el proceso
de colonización en Guatemala hace un
proceso de desingerización Y entonces
mucha gente se recompensa o muchos
Perdieron el idioma la indumentaria
nosotras debemos en nuestros tejidos
como parte de nuestros territorios que
hay que defender en el municipio de
Santiago Zacatepec es donde solo las
abuelas seguían Tejiendo ese arte retomó
fuerza Verónica es una de las nuevas
alumnas a punto de aprender a tejer los
diseños ancestrales a nuestras abuelas y
abuelos lucharon día con día para que
prevalezcan nuestro tejido cada hilo
cada color representa la lucha Y el
esfuerzo sobre todo la historia de
nuestro pueblo
530 años después del día en que cambió
por completo la historia de sus
ancestros indígenas Estas mujeres aún
resisten el racismo a base de hilos y
memoria